You may ask, what if the protection domain is
so large that it needs all of the hardware address
space? Maybe the file system code base is so
big that it needs the entire hardware address space. Cannot
share it with anybody else. Similarly, the code base
for the storage module is so big that it may
occupy the entire hardware address space. Now, if this were
the situation, that is, if the protection domains are so
large that they pretty much occupy the entire hardware
address space, and if the TLB does not support
address space tagging, then you have to do a
TLB flush on a context switch. If you go
from this service to this service, you need to
do a TLB flush because the memory footprint of
each of these service is as big as the
hardware address space that's available on the processor. Or in
other words, the segments overlap and therefore you have
to do a TLB flush when you do a
context switch. The cost that we've been talking about
so far is the explicit cost, that is, the
cost that is incurred for flushing the TLB at
the point of a context switch. And for small
protection domains that we want to go across, we
want to avoid that cost and we can do that
by packing them in the linear address space
provided by the hardware. But if the memory
footprint of the service is so big that
it occupies the hardware address space of the
architecture completely, the explicit cost we're going to incur,
because we have to do a TLB flush,
if the TLB is not address space tagged.
But that explicit cost is very insignificant compared
to the implicit cost that is going to be incurred. Now what do we mean by
implicit cost? We mean cache effects, that is,
the loss of locality going from this service
to this service, that the cache is not
going to have the working set of this service,
when we go from here to here. That impact is much more that the explicit cost.
For example, LeKay shows that on the
specific architecture in which they implemented L3, which
is a Pentium architecture. It had 32
entries for kernel translations and 64 entries for
user translations. Even if you want to flush the entire TLB, all the entries in
the TLB, it takes 864 cycles to do that. But, the loss of locality, when a
service goes from this to this, in terms of cache
effects is going to be much more significant because, with a
large address space you expect that you're doing more work
in the subsystem. And the implicit costs are going to dominate.